hey what's up guys my name is shannon i
hope you guys are having a fantastic
holiday season
i sure am having a busy one something a
little bit new here today so last night
i did a live stream i streamed quite
often on twitter tv slash the channel
and i was thinking to myself after the
stream that
this live stream i think would be quite
useful to a lot of people
to see more or less my process when it
comes to actually implementing a feature
and specifically something that i've
never done before because last night
what we decided to do was
mouse picking so that we could actually
select an object in our
3d scene in the game engine series
version of hazel
using a new technique that i had never
done before and so this was kind of my
interpretation of
i guess that technique and me kind of
stumbling through it and getting
getting it to work in in a way that i
thought was useful
and i kind of walk through my thought
process and ask the questions from the
stream and this kind of content i think
while it's quite long i think this is
going to be like
gonna end up being like an hour and a
half long or something like that uh it's
probably gonna be quite useful to a lot
of you to see how
like what what my work actually looks
like rather than just presenting you
with the game engine series where
everything's already been worked out
because i know that a lot of you
can't make it to all the live streams
and so you end up missing
that kind of experience now if you can't
make it to live streams but you really
want more of this content i do actually
upload all of my live streams in their
entirety for my patreon supporters so if
you support me with at least five
dollars per month you'll get access to
my entire backlog of live streams
so if you find that you really enjoy
this content and you don't mind
supporting me and hazel and everything
that i'm doing
then patreon.com is a good way to get
more of what you're about to see anyway
please let me know if you guys
enjoy this content because i might do
more of these kind of live streams i've
even thought about editing together some
of my live streams into more concise
blocks because
i find that you know naturally during
the course of a stream cool stuff ends
up happening you know chat asks
questions that i answer
and i think that's a lot of a lot of
interesting stuff that a lot of my
youtube audience misses out on so
definitely give me some feedback in the
comment section below but other than
that i hope you guys have an amazing
christmas and
a very happy new year and i will see you
next year no i'm gonna make more videos
this year
i'll see you next time goodbye anyway so
we have this kind of
uh pink cube i think we have the editor
camera now we have gizmos i guess like
picking would be a natural next step
but i also don't know if um
that's something we really want to do
yet
so so ray so so mouse picking is an
interesting problem
right because there's varying
solutions there's a lot of solutions to
it and some of them
are so aside from just having pros and
cons and not even thinking about things
like performance
um they in general
um they give you they they
almost solve different problems right so
as an example
um a very very interesting like a very
simple way to
solve it i guess is to um basically
project the
mouse position as a ray going from the
camera's frosting into 3d space
into whatever pixel we're looking at
right because that's basically the
reverse of what we actually do
so when we render something we have this
like representation of
an object of vertices in world space
they don't have to be
immediate like usually they're in local
space that we multiply with like a
transform matrix
which brings them into world space and
then we
multiply it by essentially another
transform matrix which is the camera's
view because we want to position it
based
like relative to the camera and where
the camera is in the world
and then finally we multiply with a
projection matrix which projects it
into like a negative one to one space
which is eventually what we see
um on the screen now if we were to
reverse that because we can easily just
from the mouse
cursor calculate where the mouse is in
that negative one-to-one space where the
pixels eventually
um end up so if we take it through that
and then we multiply it with the inverse
of the view projection matrix of the
camera
then we wind up with having basically a
point in 3d space and a direction as
well because the camera has orientation
we essentially because we have that
point which is the point is just the
origin is just the camera's position
and then the orientation dictates the
camera the the direction of the ray
and then the um range between negative
one to one
um basically dictates where in the
frostum it is so if we do that
we wind up with a ray in 3d space in
world space
and so all we have to do is do a
collision check between that ray
and usually first the boundary box of
all the meshes
and then eventually like the actual
individual triangles
and that's an easy way to see whether or
not
we actually have clicked on an object in
3d space that has a lot of benefits
and some drawbacks the benefits are
because we are physically projecting a
rain in 3d space
we have a lot of information about what
happens with the hit
we know the distance from the camera we
know the normal of the surface
we know the uh angle between the red the
camera and the actual triangle that
we've hit
we can get any vertex attribute we want
and so when you think about applications
such as vertex painting
like if i want to paint a texture on
this uh surface and obviously it's in 3d
space
we need to project array because if we
don't do that we can't figure out
where stuff goes right in the texture
because obviously if you
um think about clicking here not only do
we have the triangle
information we can actually use some
interpolation to work out the actual
texture coordinate
and then therefore paint into that
portion of the texture and do some
pretty cool stuff
right so we actually um get a lot of
benefits from that
now the drawbacks i i talked about a
little bit um
about them in my game engine
uh no in the hazel in the last hazel
devlog which was about skeletal
animation
so the problem is that if we have an
animated mesh
that doesn't work but then again for an
animated mesh you don't need vertex
painting so there's another method
that's quite common
which is basically just drawing having
an additional render pass
which draws every object with a
different color id with a different
color
and based on like so in other words we
draw one object with
this color then the next object with
this color every draw call has a
different color
presumably every draw call is a mesh if
you have sub meshes you can split it up
so that every
um submesh has a different color it
doesn't really matter
you're basically setting a uniform color
it can be whatever it wants right
and then that render pass will basically
output it now you can you can do this in
your main pass as well
um it's possible to just you know use
multiple render targets i guess hook up
a different i've never done this before
by the way so i have no idea what i'm
doing
but um it's definitely possible to hook
up another round of target
and then output like the color id of the
object into one place and then the
um is there an actual draw id i guess
that only applies for instance rendering
but maybe a draw id is actually built
into glsl i'm not sure though
like a draw probably not though why
would that exist
if it's not instanced anyway
um the point is you render each object
or each submesh or whatever on earth you
decide to
with a different color onto a texture
into a frame buffer
obviously the frame buffer is the same
size as the screen it's very easy to
figure out where the mouse is in a 2d
coordinate
then you just have to work out hey when
i click on this and i get a read back of
that texture
into cpu which is a little bit of a slow
part
right but if you can get those pixels on
the cpu and actually just do a little
check you can
essentially sample that color right and
i guess you could do this on the gpu and
have some kind of weird output but
that's that's also weird usually you do
a read back to the cpu and just do it on
the cpu
um and you can figure out hey i've
clicked on this color
what object id is this and then you can
select the object that way
so that's kind of um also an acceptable
solution
now it's def it's it's
it's not bad but you literally
it's very like it's very
it's very black and white it's very
binary it's very like you know you've
clicked on object
five that's all you get which for
you know for selection is probably good
enough
but for you know stuff like vertex
painting or any other like
information that you may want it's
garbage
um and also you have that little
potential gpu store i don't think if
that really matters because you can just
get it the next frame
um and in a threaded renderer
you usually are one frame behind anyway
so i don't think it's a huge weight
i don't think i don't think it's huge
but anyway
um my point is that that's also that
that's probably what we'll end up doing
i imagine that we'll have both solutions
though that's pretty standard because
again sometimes as i said you do want to
know exactly what you're looking at but
sometimes it doesn't matter
so that's probably what we'll um explore
um
so we could try and jam that in now
because i guess one of the one of the
natural progressions to this
is i want to be able to actually select
something
and um you know having to click on stuff
kind of sucks doesn't it right like
having to select stuff in the scene
hierarchy panel kind of sucks
so i think maybe we can actually make it
so that we can just click on something
now we're dealing with sprites at the
moment potentially in 2d space but again
it's not really in 2d space i don't
think it matters
that it's not in 2d space i think that
if you just if you just pretend like if
you just
say that okay hazel's in 3d sure you can
render the cameras orthographic you can
use
this or that but math for mathematical
purposes
you know we can just say
um
sorry
just reply something okay so yeah so
um mathematically and for the purposes
of this like it doesn't really matter
you know we can just still do that
object id thing and then i mean because
that
you know at the end of the day it
doesn't matter again we're just
rendering
all of our objects in flat colors it's
kind of like this even this makes sense
these are all flat colors right
this whole object that we're rendering
which is like um
you know the uh which one is this
this is the that's the camera
the left one right said left if i this
whole left is a particular pink
it's this this is the color value of it
this is the hex value of it right
um it makes sense um
you know if you click on that you can
just do a reversal look up and figure
out
so let's let's try and integrate
something like that i think
um i don't know if i want to add another
frame buffer to our current frame buffer
like sorry add another texture
attachment to our frame buffer so that
we can use multiple render targets
or if i want to do this as a completely
separate pass the reason is this is
not needed whatsoever in runtime it's
just an editor thing
and if it's just an editor thing it can
be in the editor runtime because like
you know if you're debugging or whatever
you might still want to select an object
of your stuff based like from the mouse
pointer
um
no so okay so the
other the what napoleon's saying um
doesn't really um
in order for you to do that though you
need
to basically use up a lot more texture
bandwidth
right because you're basically creating
a g buffer in that in that sense
um which is a lot of texture like that
that can be a lot of textures i don't
know maybe i'm still thinking in like
mobile terms because
that's where most of my like
professional experience has been in
but that's a lot like a g buffer is
quite a lot of bandwidth um
and you probably will have like we will
have some sort of
g buffer-esque things right
um it isn't yeah and again we're like
i'm not gonna get too much into this um
i get that it's in an edit on a
workstation pc but remember we have to
picture debugging
as well right like i'm on a mobile
device something's wrong i want to be
able to tap on an object to see exactly
what the deal is right um and again that
i agree that that's more of like a let's
solve that problem when we even get onto
mobile devices it doesn't matter we can
still have this solution here
but um
oh no sorry you're talking about vertex
painting um
no yeah no yeah of course you'll never
be doing vertex painting most likely on
a mobile device unless you've made a
game that
does that so yeah that's a good point
and i think we will we will have
g buffer like we will have auxiliary
buffers with information such as not
like world world space normals and other
stuff like that
because we'll need them for post
processing effects
and stuff like that right so that that's
that's definitely going to be needed
um so yeah like ultimately it's not a
huge deal
we'll see um again like the ray stuff is
nice
i like the ray stuff because you know
you you do get like
distance between camera and object is
really easy to compute there's a lot of
stuff that's easy to compute and i think
it might even be faster because once you
start reading back four or five textures
per frame from the gpu back to the cpu
to work out certain things
that can be really annoying
um ray tracing plans and fog i don't
know not for a while
i don't want to be right racing but
that's just not needed
yet all right so how
how would we do that how would we do
that so again i am thinking of just
doing it in an additional render pass we
do have a frame of a class that is
i don't know what it's like i think i
might rewrite it soon to be more like
the
hazel dev frame buffer which is just
better
um because we we do like we need this to
be a bit more flexible
right at the moment we create a frame
buffer what does it do
we give it a specification which is just
basically
this junk and then it creates um
[Music]
then it creates a very uh
straightforward
texture rgba only texture
with linear filtering
and adds the depth stencil attachment to
it which is you know
which is great for our main buffer but
not good for
anything else so we probably need to
create a better
situation for that now
i rewrote the framework for class in
hazel dev recently i mean the hazel dev
class before the rewrite was already
more advanced than this obviously
um have i implemented ray racing porn no
i've not i've never done any real-time
race racing stuff before
so i'm quite excited to do that
so if we look at the frame buffer class
i'll show you guys how frame buffers
work in hazel dev
okay so this is how they work
um we have a geometry buffer this is
what it looks like you create a frame
buffer specification just like you
i guess you do in hazel as well because
it's the same kind of design
um and then what you do is you actually
set the attachments so this is these
attachments
this has a is an initialized list of
what we want so we want an rgb a16f
another
color attachment obviously an rgb a 16 f
and then a depth attachment
and if you look at what this is it's a
frame buffer attachment specification
which basically takes in a vector of
attachments and
uh these framework specifications
actually have
potentially other stuff aside from the
format but for now they're just format
and there is a constructor that takes in
format which is why
it's implicit and you can just specify a
format without having to create the
struct
then we have a whole bunch of formats
here
um and as you can see it looks quite
nice
you know if you're creating like a frame
buffer and you want two color
attachments and a depth attachment
that's what it looks like
if you want just a um just a color
attachment without a depth attachment
that's what it looks like
you know everything's really clean
everything's really nice um so i think
i'll probably end up creating something
like this for the hazel
um for not for hazel not dev
um which is what that's gonna
uh look like um like as in it's gonna
look like this i'm just looking through
all this other stuff
so
oh wow someone's playing music i don't
even hear it
um welcome edith glad to have you on
board um
i don't i don't know to be honest like
it it's it does seem like a lifelong
project at the moment because i'm sure
that
it's gonna keep evolving forever um
and it is pretty ambitious so i don't
think i'll be done anytime soon but
ultimately i want to be able to um like
a shorter term goal it's still a very
long term goal but it's shorter than
life long goal is i want to actually
uh bring hazel up to the point where i
can actually make a game with it and
then
release that game right so i want to
ship a game with hazel
that's one of the longer term goals but
one of the more serious goals
so clearly i'm working towards actually
using hazel
to create something because i'm a fairly
creative person as well and
whilst i love programming i'm not only
like a technical engineer
i'm also like an artist um and i really
want to actually like you know make a
game and
convey like certain like a story and a
feeling and stuff like that
so i definitely um i'm going to be
making games with hazel that's the idea
that is the idea um anyway so that's
kind of the way that frame buffers work
so we can probably like in hazel dev so
we can probably do something similar
here
um yeah my own music as well i write the
music for it my wife isn't
isn't like an artist i mean she's more
like a painter
um not like a digital artist but um
she's gonna like probably help out with
art and stuff for that and
i don't know exactly what the game's
gonna be yet um
i don't really wanna dedicate time to
thinking about that just yet just
because
you know there's a lot of work that
needs to be done for hazel what kind of
game do you think hazel will be good for
ideally like
most things um probably not like
everything
but i want to keep it flexible enough
where
um you know if where you can add your
own systems to deal with certain things
right because it's going to be fully
open source like
you know you will you'll just be able to
modify it or add completely different
renderers based on what you're
dealing with you know if you want
um all right
we can kind of deal with this anyway i
think but
um let's let's take a look at this so
render 2ds was currently rendering this
stuff which is a bit odd because
i mean it's clearly in 3d space and i'm
calling it render 2d but but the thing
is it is rendering 2d geometry in a way
right like there's no
um cons there shouldn't be a concept of
a z-coordinate
for this um i think that the transform
is just dictating
the the rotation because we do take in a
transform matrix
so it's a little bit weird but whatever
so the idea is um we have a scene we
don't have a scene renderer so maybe we
should introduce
like the concept of a scene renderer
um am i still live streaming
twitch just said there's a network error
yeah i think i'm live i think it was
just the the twitch stream manager
crashed
um we haven't seen render yet which i
should which i should probably
set up but
i don't know i just kind of want to see
if i can jam picking in in like five
seconds
okay good i'm live great um do i
i do no i open gl error checking um well
i mean i'm not
using gl error because that's old school
um but i do have like a callback for
rent for errors so whenever there's an
opengl error it'll set and i'll put a
breakpoint in and i can see exactly
where to cut
so it's pretty standard um
so how do we render everything so we we
just do like render a draw quad
right and that's our scene okay so this
is like
a little bit weird um for this case but
it's okay
because it's just it's not that it's
weird it's just that it hasn't been
written yet
so we have on update runtime which does
the scripts
and then we have on update editor which
doesn't do the scripts okay
but and that's mostly rendering anyway
[Music]
yeah okay so the idea is
you can do this at any time it doesn't
really matter i guess
um but you know render
to id buffer you know we could have
basically something else here
how does the frame buffer work here
that's a good question
that i just came up with
i i like to group these into scopes just
so we can like reuse names like group
and so the things get destructed as well
um what's the deal with the frame buffer
we might actually be see that's not
great this is why we need a scene
renderer
we can probably i think i think
introducing a scene renderer is going to
be something we want to do but this is
more fun
so i'm going to quickly jam this in and
see because i've never done it before as
well i'm just interested
um so
frame buffer yeah we just have a we just
have like a frame buffer here
which is a bit weird but sure
um all right
so we need a different okay yeah so this
is like this is
not correct like we don't want to do
this in editor layer but
color uh we'll call this id frame buffer
and see the the thing is like you know
yeah because you have to resize all of
them
and we should have like some kind of
maybe frame buffer pool
um and which we will in the future
actually that deals with this stuff
um because yeah we do all of this like
why is render command set clear color
and clear in here doesn't mean any sense
but whatever
and we have to have this frame buffer
here uh it's just it's just a complete
mess um let's do active scene
uh render id buffer
draw id buffer
and we can just pop in so don't worry
too much about the api here it's going
to change
um
oops
spec doesn't matter too much
[Music]
[Music]
okay um so let's go ahead and bind
this target maybe
so once once we do that though um
on we also we definitely need to
override the shader that we're using so
uh yeah and this whole thing needs to
change actually
like what's oh this is a batch renderer
which makes things even worse
because we need to like ultimately if
it's a batch
like we ultimately need to switch up
everything oh this is so annoying how
are we gonna do that
yeah that's terrible
um we might have to add it as a separate
because like the thing is like we can
still
have seven set an id per batch
um which i guess in a way is probably
what we'll have to do
um in fact
in fact that might even be better
so yeah
that's interesting isn't it um
that's quite an extension though isn't
it
like because we could have like a float
doesn't have to be a float even 32t or
something um
object id like quad id or something
right and this could be the
the sprite renderers like yeah that
could be the object id of the actual
entity this is like the entity id honest
like um honestly at this point because
it's for 2d rendering and you can just
have one sprite component that's it
um because that's just bright basically
so
[Music]
um we could do something like this
but i'm just i'm just thinking though
because like honestly
honestly maybe maybe it is worth just
just doing this in the main pass because
doing an additional pass with all of
this stuff is just it just
it's definitely more complicated
and i don't know if it's worth it so
let's let's try this
let's try this method right so
when we do draw quad um and we have a
lot of these which is a little
unfortunate but i think this would be
better
so hmm
so let's let's go to the scene class
um and instead of doing this instead of
doing it in a separate path
let's try and do it in the same path as
this so when we do a draw chord here we
use the transform and that's the only
way we draw it at the moment so
if that happens then the one thing that
that's missing here is an id for an
entity
and we don't have entity ids at the
moment which is a little bit of a
problem
um
[Music]
but ant obviously does have an id and we
have the id here
so technically speaking this is probably
okay
so i i got rid of that didn't i
dry d buffer did i delete that
no i didn't i left it okay that's okay
let's just not do that
i just want to see i think i'll get i
think at the end of the day we're just
going to get a different
um uh
oh are we still running the runtime
no wait one
all right we don't have anything to draw
[Music]
okay so entity three
and two and two yeah so we could we
clearly do have a different one here
right so we can just pass that in i
think right
um so we'll pass in like the entity id
as like a um32t
it can just be a normal ant i don't
think it has to be like a uint or
anything
[Music]
so this is interesting i've never tried
this before so if it's garbage i
apologize
i think this is what we want
i think this is the right draw quad oops
[Music]
last thing
[Music]
right
[Music]
wait um i'll fix that up later because
we don't really ever do it so
um that's okay
we don't really have a unit just
let's do it isn't it
all right all right um i think that's
mostly okay now
so we are we we physically have it there
now right so so now the only difference
is
if we look at the shader that we're
using
which i think is just the texture shader
right
now we are we exclusively using the
texture shadow
it's only one we have a load right okay
it's clearly the texture shader
so let's go ahead and add in um you know
this
as an ant i don't know how that's gonna
play
though we'll see
we can use a flat end i guess since
we're not going to be
interpolating
we need to clean up these shadows and
make them more like welcome compatible
as well
let's go ahead and switch this little
core in here
um okay where's my object id
all right so let's go ahead and add um
a little id buffer output
can we just write an int out well you
might be able to i'm not sure entirely
no i'm in a fifth note four maybe
like an ibex iv
we don't even need that really we just
have a red buffer
like what's the point of that right
i'm not really sure um if that even
exists
let's quickly go to our frame buffer
um what are our
what's the deal for a text image 2d
what's the deal gel red
[Music]
could do that glr8
glr8
all right i integer
ui hmm but is that eight bits of
that's not good is it
rgba 32
i
ah here we go r32i that's probably what
i want
glr32i i've never done this before as i
mentioned like 500 times so
we'll see what happens so let's do
um
this so that's my deeper heart
attachment
and this is so temporary again when i
actually do this for the gaming series i
think i'm gonna rewrite this
this class first because um
obviously this is silly
so gl what was it r32i
never used that format before that's an
internal format isn't it yeah
sized internal now for an actual format
though
i think gel red is probably what we're
dealing with right
gl red r32i okay and i don't know
if this should be
[Music]
i don't know if this needs to be
unsigned right
unsigned oh is this an outside end
i guess it doesn't matter actually we'll
leave it at that
no i don't know about definitely doesn't
need to be near well we're not gonna be
sampling from it though so
probably just gonna be like a little
storage take storage or um
a render buffer or something i
all
i don't know i think that's okay
probably
might have to hook this up to render dog
because it's a bit weird so by that
logic
this should be okay um and then we
should just be able to output that
so weird
so weird okay
um so yeah so so that this just gets
done in our main parts as i said
let's just i guess it should just work
shouldn't it
let's see what we got
[Music]
um well yeah for this we can just use
empty
and we probably want like a pixel buffer
or something else
i'm just doing it as a frame buffer
and it's not happy with this either
and i'm not sure why
remember pressing complete attach the
type and format combination okay yeah
it's the format so maybe this is
uh
glint that's a bit weird
yeah i didn't think that would
but that seems like what it should be
um what are the format options
[Music]
no no no format sorry not that's not for
that's type
um format what that that can't be right
oh that's the internal format oh whoops
i got them the other rounds
why are you still upset
texture type and format combination is
not valid
but it's literally in the documentation
internal format 32i
format red
that's definitely valid according to the
documentation it's literally written
as a pair
oh no that's a size internal format and
a base internal
format but what about the format itself
but it's also gel red oh it has to be
red
integer i think oh my goodness
why was it showing me bass internal
formats who cares about that
oh great okay it's not happy about
something
[Music]
um
is it here
really jailed robot this is not happy
about
should i have done this after this
what
maybe that's not how you do it
oh it's color attachment
all right
all right no errors
and we do actually see something and no
errors
so what should be happening now is we
should actually have a buffer of
weirdness going on and
let's see if we can actually read that
back now
um okay
now i assume this will be one frame
behind but
if we just do gl read buffer
gl color attachment one
will read pixels
xy with the height format
this is promising probably not this i
know there's something called a pixel
buffer or something that we can use
instead for
read backs instead of a frame buffer
color attachment but this should
work um i know i'm doing open gel coding
here
which i think is illegal like literally
it's not gonna work so
uh like i think we haven't included it
so active scene
uh pixel don't know what the
on earth i don't care i just need to
call a function here
pixel for me
okay so if we just do like um
uh this is a coordinate what coordinate
xy window coordinates of the first pixel
this this is what like it's a pixel
right so it's literally supposed to be
with height and size and stuff
so maybe we can just do because we will
have to get us done anyway
maybe we can just do this um
[Music]
um viewport okay how do we get the
i need the mouse cursor in a viewport
space or something
for space so it's literally we can just
use yeast
and i think that's it just i'm going to
get mouse position
maybe we'll be good enough
okay so we'll okay xy with height
this
giant
that's it and then what data is the
output all right
i don't really need buffer size um so
ants pixel
apparently apparently that that's it
um
might also be upside down but we will
see
what's happened
can't mix integer and non-integer data
what does that mean is this red integer
or something it doesn't say that that's
a thing
maybe just didn't didn't uh explain it
no yeah it just didn't explain it um
these are some weird mouse coordinates
by the way
okay that's not remotely what i wanted
thank you
again i'm gooey um so
i think the viewport bounds is what we
need to do here for our max just to
normalize it and i think that's probably
about it and then there's also some
clipping going on
we've always been height and be divided
by that which is
probably not necessary but
do you need to do something like that
okay so let's try this a bit more bit
better
now the viewbot bounds what are there
what are they because i don't think we
have them
um we just get them by doing this stuff
probably a little it's probably healthy
to have that anyway
i don't know if we necessarily need them
because we do have some kind of
i am gooey viewport stuff here
um so i want to see what we have
we've got people panel size get content
region available
is that the same no this is when it has
been a position
which i don't think we even do we do our
window width and height this is going to
be useful for other stuff obviously as
well
now the real question is do we do this
before the imager after the image okay
so let's just stick that in here what's
this viewport offset
ah this is before we draw the image
so like here
and then for people bounds which is
we'll see what bounds
it's that let's go ahead and
stick that somewhere
now we have people bounds and now this
should maybe work
um the thing is it's just it's not going
to go past a particular
like it might be outside of the viewport
which i don't know what's going to
happen in that case actually
we do have that's why we have a width
and height just in case we need to deal
with that but
i don't really know
all right so now this is like zero zero
you can see we can go past as well okay
so let's let's see what on earth happens
here okay well we're not crashing we're
not getting gl errors so now the only
thing that we need to maybe do
is return an end here and maybe like
magic it will work
i have serious doubts about that
but you know
maybe it will be the best
oh well it seems to change weirdly
enough
hmm
what are we clearing the buffer oh zero
um i have a feeling it's flipped
oh i saw a one there
and if it were if it were flipped then
but why are these changing it's a bit
weird let me clear the buffer before we
render maybe but i don't know if that's
something that's happening
does jail clear clear all the
color buffers
what does jail clear do
or like all of the draw buffers i guess
maybe
because we have a render command clear
obviously so we set the clear color to
that
which you know is a little weird because
because i obviously want to clear um
the buffer to a different
[Music]
something else
you can do a little clear text image
okay that's interesting we can do that
on bind i guess just to be
just to test it out better but basically
i think that um
yeah if we do clear text image we use
the id attachment
level zero format geo
red integer glance
then we clear it to
uh clear value
which since we're dealing with this i
can just set it to negative one right
this might work um i mean i guess it
should right
still still is weird isn't it
so right there it seems to be zero but
i'm not sure why i'm getting all these
weird values
because i shouldn't be right
oops um
[Music]
pretty sure this is this is in fact the
function i'm using um
but the thing is let me just make sure
maybe
oh no
three three two
zero
and i'm i'm definitely not like using
any other functions right
not
hmm odd
odd odd odds um yeah the other thing
could be the uh
um because i'm pretty sure it isn't
pixels right uh is there just the um
the fact that we might need to set my to
viewport
height minus my but that's not you know
causing all of this anyway i think
ah it doesn't seem to be
ah well actually
it does seem to work
it seems to work perfectly
it's just that yeah
it's working perfectly it's just the the
numbers are
not really correct
but if you look at this
you'll see that when i put my mouse over
a certain area it's one number then as
soon as i hit the left
face you can see it changed right
between the blank space and the left
face
when i got to the right face it also
changed as you can see and it's constant
for the whole
area and then for the top face is zero
and it's constant for that whole area
so i'm not sure really what happened
there but
location five in a object id
should be the fifth one should be an end
i have a feeling that something's going
wrong there
maybe it's taking it in as a float maybe
we don't have an end
in our buffer situation or something i'm
not sure
this happens in the vertex array maybe
oh wait you need to use i you need to
use int pointer there's a special
function of vertex a trib
that's that's used for integers so you
can't actually use this here
so hazel dev as an example i think this
is an opengl pipeline
has um has this situation
see if the base type is int it uses this
otherwise it does the other thing
so that's something that we need to do
um
and otherwise i think it's the same like
there's no normalization in
other stuff but that's probably why so
basically um let's grab this
because you can see we're doing mat
three
map three map four why do we even have
that
wait what
what what is this code
why do we have this attrib divider and
matrices
this is like for instance rendering
i remember doing that who did that
that's odd oh well
yeah so for integers we'll um and maybe
for bull i'm not sure about bullying
but let's grab this for now it's very
weird
um vertex attrib i pointer
and i think basically normalized goes
away and i think everything else is
pretty much the same
so maybe let's try now and let's see if
we get the same result
because um i'm
feeling i don't know if this will work
or not but
no it doesn't doesn't seem oh there we
go it worked
right so these are still weird values i
don't know why it's clearing that but
now you can see
we actually get zero three 2 so it works
works perfectly but then if we're
outside of the range it's a weird value
and i'm not sure why that is it should
be negative one
um which obviously should be like a
signed integer
should be able to be negative one so
why that's happening is beyond me
um
we should also do a different thing
where
where yeah
let's collect all the pixels for some
weird reason so
um yeah so this should only happen i
guess
if
uh mx is greater than zero and
greater or equal to zero
uh what even are these i know i'm using
auto but what are these
floats i don't know why that floats
let's um
thank you for the prime subscriptions in
cinli usan sorry i don't know how to
pronounce the
um
hmm
yeah mouse coordinates is floats and
doubles are sometimes annoying sometimes
they're not just purely because of
the mathematical purpose um because you
know
if it's an integer and you divide by it
so if i'm getting the viewport with
and it's an int and i divide by that i
could accidentally wind up with a
rounding error because it doesn't
integer division without me knowing so
in that case floats are kind of useful
but yeah and a lot of i agree with you
it's kind of like a dilemma because i
don't you don't know if it's gonna work
like it's gonna be useful or not
um anyway uh i'm just making sure that i
got my ranges right and it looks like i
do
so um that's narrowed down a little bit
and then the other thing that i want to
do
um and by the way i think at this point
we can move we'll assume we can move it
into the other thing but also yeah i
still don't understand why
when i bind my frame buffer
it's because it clears it later i think
i like isn't it i think it clears it
again and maybe that throws it off
because it doesn't clear here so clear
color and then a clear and then i think
that clears both
so in a way that's a bit weird so let's
do this
which is i know it's stupid um but it's
just temporary just to see if it's
working now this is
this is like i'm preparing i'm planning
you could say i'm planning a video
yeah there you go there's your negative
one all right everything's working
now so now you can see we have uh if
we're not over an object
we have negative one and then as soon as
we're over something we have the object
id
and this is even like batch rendering
and everything's working all right
so now the last thing that remains right
the last thing that remains is basically
to make it so that
this only this code only runs if we
click
and that of course is just us going to
on event um
we don't have a mouse click event yet
that's okay on mouse button pressed
mouse button pressed event
so this is this doesn't even do the
weird color thing you don't need a color
you just
like output the object id into a
separate buffer like
don't need a color at all
what is this like mouse
mouse mouse
[Music]
button left
then we do this
this is the thing that you might
consider doing in hazel dev yes
absolutely we need to do it in hazel dev
because of animated meshes so
this is yeah definitely gonna be done in
hazeldev with a better api though of
course
uh mouse button process returning
well traditional picking is the ray cast
it's like a geometry intersection with a
ray cast
oh cinderson thank you so much for the
10 donation
glad you've been enjoying the stream
required buff is missing it's cause i
clicked or did something weird
that's okay
i shouldn't have clicked yet well as in
i shouldn't have allowed to click
because we have
no buffer i guess that we rendered to
and also this shouldn't happen if i
press alt and there's a number of
reasons why it shouldn't happen oh
actually it's just not working at all
all right that's okay um i know why that
is because we're not about we haven't
bound a buffer
so um but we shouldn't have a buffer
like i don't think we
ever unfind it right so that's a bit odd
isn't it
um
i mean i mean i don't really like know
if this is like
we could just do this every frame just
because i think like you know we might
want to hover over
something and see some information so i
don't even know of doing it
like press press should be the selection
for sure but
hovering over something maybe should be
processed every frame and that would
um probably make this code a little bit
better but i'm not sure why oh we
actually do unbind it wow
that's that's not necessary um
[Music]
mouse how mouse picking works is disc is
absolutely dependent on whoa
okay we do need to unbind it how
how mouse picking works is completely
dependent on how you implement it
there's different ways of doing it
um
i'm confused as to why that doesn't
render anything if you leave the buffer
bound
because surely something else binds like
the imgui buffer or something else
happens
i'm not really sure why that happened at
all but whatever
um all right so now um you can see that
if we click somewhere we get negative
one if we click on one of these
ideally we'd get what we what we want
but we don't
um
i have to say my active scene might be
empty okay this is i don't want to do it
this way anyway this was just to test
something
um because what i want to do is i just
want to leave it here
um once we render everything of course
um and
at this point in time is when we do the
uh we now we now have an active object
id and that's kind of the point
so the cool thing we can do now is have
m entity
m hovered entity
right and this hovered entity is going
to be zero by default
but then here if we actually get back a
pixel that isn't zero
um then we have something so basically
uh
zero zero is a valid end thing um which
is why we need to basically get that
pixel back and then if pixel equals
negative one
we can set hover density equal to entity
which by the way will just
as far as i'm concerned we'll just set
the entity handle
to be null right which is what we want
otherwise right
um so we can do a little ternary
operator here actually
so if it's negative one we'll set it to
entity
um otherwise we'll set it to and this is
the cool part
we can just set it to entity
um pixel and then active same because
the color is the value
the color is the id so actually we wind
up with something pretty cool
um active scenes are rough so we just
need to make sure that we get the raw
pointer
um but that's it pretty cool right
um and that's our kind of handle so now
now let's go into here and do i'm going
text
harvard entity
this is where it gets fun right so for
now we'll do
a hover density of like a un 32 t or
whatever
i think that should show up as like
percentage d should be okay
right um now what do you want
entity so it wants an actual end handle
sorry what was this man
how's that this better
[Music]
so now we have a hobbit entity there
which has a stupid value at the moment
but uh pink cube pink cube
but now you can see as we hover over
something we get a value now i don't
definitely don't want it to be zero but
that's just because it's like null or
whatever
so um i don't know though
because it definitely shouldn't be i'm
not sure why
does that actually yeah that that does
construct a smell
a little bit weird isn't it um
[Music]
that's weird isn't it
i guess we're casting it to you and 32t
okay
so harvard entity do a string instead
um okay and yeah as i said this is where
it gets interesting so we can do if
um hover identity
doesn't equal and
null right and then we've actually got
an sc so we could do
sd string name equals um
null or whatever
um hover density get component
every everything has a tag component
and you can probably see where this is
going name equals that
dot we should have an implicit
constructor but whatever i mean implicit
operator but whatever
tag name dot c string all right
so this is even more exciting right
a piece of junk
why are you doing this to me
oh um
i don't know if that's necessarily a
good way to do it though
i'm sorry i i'm not sure oh we actually
have that sorry my bad
we actually have that so that returns
the energy handles
so um that should work i'm not sure why
it's being a jerk
maybe because it doesn't know if it's
whatever
um we're doing like some some um mouse
picking
for the stuff so okay
so if you pay attention to this hobbit
entity now you can see it says null
right we don't have any entities in the
scene
so that's to be expected but then if we
uh load up pink cube it still says null
and then you can see when we actually
hover over it
now instead of having a stupid id it
actually says the name of the entity
so we have null and then obviously top
right left
we see all this stuff and then the final
piece of the puzzle which is the
exciting part i guess
is the selection and the selection is
just
us doing left
the selection is just us basically going
into this
piece of code that i already wrote and
then just saying that
um i guess like we have a we have a
selection right
i think it's in the scene hierarchy
panel
we have some kind of like either set
selected we have a get selected entity
we can't set a selected entity so that's
what we need to do now right so set
selected entity um
and then that will just uh well i guess
everything is like that's the nice thing
about i'm going as well everything's
immediate mode
so we can just do selection context
equals entity right um
presumably taking in an actual entity
like this
um and that's kind of it like
we don't have i don't think we have to
do anything else um and it should just
update to the selectedness here
uh and then the final thing is we also
have
i think it's it's like a um
a callback or no i think we just get
it's like a density every frame don't we
so well because what we do here we do
we do um
in the i'm gizmo stuff how do we get
this light identity
we just get
transform transformer i use selected
density is what exactly seen hierarchy
panel
so actually seen hierarchy panel uh my
secure gif thank you so much for your
subscription welcome welcome to this
stream
and to the family of subscribers
um yeah so so realistically
right with the mouse button press all we
need to do is just set the scene
hierarchy panel then
set the selected entity to um this
identity if there is something right so
it it's interesting how this works
because
um i think you can just clear this so
you can set the selection context to
null
that's fine right because we can
obviously oh we can't deselect stuff at
the moment
this is gonna make things even better i
think um
because uh i think yeah
actually so i think we literally just
always set it to whatever entity we're
hovering over and that's
that's literally it so let's see if this
works
all right so um now if i
you can see what i'm hovering over and
if i click i should be able to select
the right one and of course with
with these gizmos is even better now um
we don't want it to with some other
things we will probably want to tidy up
so for example we don't really want this
to work with
if we're pressing alt and stuff like
that because alt is for
um there's a lot of things if the gizmo
is present we also don't want to do it
so like i think there's like um
uh
press and i'm quizmo is active or he's
using
we want that to be false and
um input is key pressed
key like left alt i don't know you
probably want to want to have like a
bunch of stuff here
um but
and stream i'll answer your questions in
a minute
um
okay that's just upset now so angry is
using has to be false and
that has to be not pressed sorry
okay so if i'm actually moving i
obviously don't want the selection to
change and you can see it's not
right um and then obviously if i also
use alt
i don't want the selection to change and
it's not
so there you go let's create a new
entity
let's add a sprite renderer component to
it now i can select the new entity
and everything does look pretty flawless
oh oh that's weird okay so
um the other thing that we need to do
there's actually one more
and that's um i'm quizmo
is over has to be false because
in that scenario as you saw um i hadn't
yet begun using i haven't
i haven't begun to use i'm gizmo yet for
actual like manipulation
but it was still at a point where it was
like over something else and it was
ruining everything so
so that's the this one i can select the
white one presumably yeah even the pixel
like that
well
okay i can still use i'm wismo while
using alt but that's an i'm gizmo
problem like as in you just need to add
a little check to make sure you're not
pressing alt because alt is for the
camera movement and if you start moving
the camera you probably want to stop
your manipulation
but yeah that's that's picking um really
easy let's open a different scene
like this 3d example obviously we can
pick um
this stuff up pretty easily and
everything is working flawlessly all
right
so anyway any questions there were some
questions so wouldn't it affect the
frame time
especially when reading a couple guys
saying no it won't um
it doesn't really matter how complicated
the scene is because you're rendering it
you're
setting a pixel id per like just for
every pixel the fragment shader runs
through
um so yes like you could say maybe like
it probably would scale
with a scene but it's not you're never
gonna it's never gonna be a while now
um
[Music]
maybe the mouse picking started during
run time
it could also be the mouse click
triggers the additional render pass
there is no additional render pass
so the color ids get generated as part
of the one and only render pass there's
exactly one render path in this whole
thing
it's just that we output to multiple
frame buffers we output to a color
buffer which is what we display
and we output to that object id buffer
that we can then
um read back from okay so there is no if
this is all done in one render pass
i'm not sure it understands how it works
some already have interest ideas and you
mouse pick by rendering to them to
interdetect to the fbo
and fetch the text all the mouses on
kind of yeah basically so
every object has an id because it's
stored in an empty component system
and that id happens to be something like
zero one two whatever
right i mean it's just pictured as like
an integer 0 1 2 3
whatever right so what i'm doing is i'm
taking that object id and then when i
actually render
a sprite um like this when i actually
render a quad
i'm into the vertex data of each vertex
that makes up this quad which is
four vertices because we use six indices
right so each one of these four vertices
actually contains the object id so the
entity id the sword and end or an entity
the
ecs system that we're using we grab that
id and we actually pack it into the
vertex data
and that way when we do the rendering
for this sprite we can actually
output that exact entity id which we
know is an int
it's an it's one single integer into a
texture
that is only an into 32 texture so it's
not like your
classic rgba texture is just one channel
per pixel and that channel is an integer
that's the type of data 32-bit integer
um and then then that way we end up with
a texture that contains for every pixel
on the screen
it contains an integer and that integer
is either negative one which means
there's no
object there or every pixel that makes
up an object
has that that object id there so when we
then move our mouse
um and then uh read back from that
texture on the cpu and actually see what
value is
at that mouse coordinate we either get
negative one
if there's no object or an actual id or
like a you know zero one two three
whatever
which is whatever object that pixel
belongs to
that's it
can you show us they're picking a buff
around a dog i can it's
not gonna be that useful um to look at
that
sorry i completely butchered that
um because uh let me see what's up here
um it's not going to be uh it's not
going to be that useful because
they're not like colors that you can
really visualize i you'll see like it's
you know 0 1 2
like they're very small numbers so
they'll be mostly black probably
um but we can still see what we get i
think
[Music]
okay so if we look at something like
this i'll zoom in a bit
[Music]
is it taking so long um
then you can see we have one color pass
with two targets
and depth um
[Music]
so where's this so this is the draw
elements i can kind of see it i guess
um this is the color buffer so uh
there's a way to maybe we can change the
channels
can we see what we're sampling there
yeah so so basically this is all
negative one
this top one is zero which is why it's
black and this is one
and two it's just they're both showing
up as if they're float textures which is
the problem
um but i think you can actually view the
data somehow
um i don't know why i'm playing with
that uh how do i view the buffer data
it'd be good if it actually told me
because it's clearly an end no the
render dock knows an
end oh you can see it here so
this is very difficult to see um
but there's a number over here i don't
know if you guys can see that it says
negative one at the moment
if i put my mouse here and right click
to pick that see how it says two now
and this says one oh sorry three and
this says zero
um the reason there's no one is like a
zero
three and two is because the camera must
be object
or entity id one right is that a custom
range
um oh yeah okay
well i don't know if there's a point to
doing that
yeah i guess that kind of works as well
um
[Music]
zero to three or whatever so you can
that's still zero and you can see these
are different colors basically so
yeah um would it be possible to 43 model
from a 3d software package well
hazel dev you can um you can do that in
hazel dev because we uh
you can load 3d models obviously you can
check out you can check out the latest
hazel
devlog on my youtube channel um but we
can't do that
um yet here will i add an outline that
can hazeldev of course eventually
everything that's in hazel there will
slowly make its way to
this how did you manage to render the
vulcan scene to i'm gui
as i remember it's using an iron texture
id to draw yeah i had to modify i'm
going to
let it have to let it work so instead of
taking in a texture id i take in like a
um a vulcan like texture
well the whole texture info thing so
like the image view the image and the
view i think or something like that
um and then you can combine that and
render that um if you go through my
vulcan streams i think they're on
patreon you can see how i did that
i'm pretty sure i showed that on a
stream maybe i didn't actually i
probably didn't
i think that was something i did
off-stream um anyway yeah so that that's
how the color stuff works um it's pretty
simple
um hopefully you saw that it was fairly
simple it's just
you know we're going through every pixel
rendering its color to this buffer but
here
instead of rendering the color of the
sprite we're rendering the object id and
obviously it doesn't matter if this is
3d rendering or 2d rendering or whatever
it's just for each rasterized pixel
we're outputting the object id
that's it will i be uploading
to more churno yes i will i'm sorry um
i've just been very busy lately and i
definitely am
you know the main channel takes priority
um
cool uh does anyone have any other
questions before i end the stream
i kind of like the sanji hover thing
it's it's nice because we can see what
we're hovering over
but yeah it definitely like even like a
small change like i mean i guess it's
not like a tiny change but a small
change like this
um you know makes makes the editor so
much more usable now because
object selection object picking um is uh
definitely very useful
we don't have an outline yet so it's
hard to see what's picked but you can
definitely see it
be reflected in like you know the scene
um
hierarchy panel as well
all right cool um all right stream well
i hope you enjoyed
the live stream um
i will uh probably
i should probably record an episode
based on this but again this was done
today i did it in a fairly messy way
i just wanted to make sure that it
actually works it was like part of my
planning process
um i just wanted to jam it in basically
as quickly as possible and see if it
worked
i'm curious i'm a little bit curious as
to how other people do it if they use it
with like the pixel
um buffers or something like that
instead of just a frame buffer texture
like i did
i'm also not sure what the performance
is like here i don't really
care much i think it seems to work
pretty well and i don't think it's going
to be dreadfully awful
does this perform as good as like making
a triangle intersection
um i imagine this will perform better
actually i think that
um there's probably there's definitely
that kind of gpus
like sometimes like a stall but like
there is a
slight more a slightly higher gpu cost
but
um this will scale extremely well unlike
the triangle thing so the triangle thing
if you have a very
dense mesh or if you have a
huge 3d scene then it's going to be a
nightmare
trying to get that to scale if like i
think even in hazel dev if you
if you load something huge like a
million triangles plus
then um it's going to take it it took
like a few frames
that like every time you click your
mouse there's like a few frames of like
nothing it takes a few frames to
actually do the 150 milliseconds or
whatever i think it was when i checked
it last
whereas this will always be instant
because it's not dependent on the
complexity of the scene
it's literally just dependent on the
size of your frame puffer which is
always going to be okay
so this is a much better way of doing it
it just gives you it just gives you less
information back